hi there this is Jessica from Germany do
you believe in any other thing than
human life and the universe hi Jessica
do I believe in other things than human
life in the universe well yes I think
it's very likely and I don't know
whether we'll ever know but it's
certainly a good question to approach
scientifically to make a guess you could
say well we believe that there are about
a hundred billion galaxies that we could
observe with our telescopes and that
each of those galaxies has a hundred
billion stars in it and that at least in
our galaxy about 10% of the stars have
planets so that means there's an immense
number of places that life could
potentially exist around stars elsewhere
in the universe and it seems pretty
likely to me that that would happen
there's an awful lot of chances for it
to occur now will we find it well we
have to try and we have many methods to
try we will probably in the next few
years discover an earth-like planet
around a sun-like star with the
observing of Observatory recently
launched called Kepler and other
competing projects might even get there
sooner if they're lucky so we certainly
will find places where life could exist
I think in the next few years and it'll
take probably a few more decades to tell
whether those places could possibly
support life whether they have the right
chemical composition with water and
carbon dioxide and signs of life such as
oxygen which is produced here by plants
and which wouldn't occur here on the
earth without those plants so we can
tell from a distance if a planet is
alive if that planet is like Earth
people also ask could there be
intelligent life and I think yes I don't
think there's any reason to think that
our situation is so unusual that there
could be no intelligent life elsewhere
in the universe on the other hand
calculation says the universe is very
large and so it's very unlikely that
we'll find the places where other people
are living and sending us messages we're
looking but we haven't found anything
yet so here the problem is just that the
Unity universe is too large for us to be
sure we'll ever find those other people